la pression était forte les questions
incessantes le gouvernement tente une
réponse qui aura un rapporteur spécial
indépendant
qui se chargera de déterminer les
prochaines étapes Justin Trudeau voit
donc désigner une sorte de nouvelle
expert indépendante qui aura la tâche de
faire des recommandations au
gouvernement
en
la nécessité indépendantes qu'est-ce
qu'on devrait faire en plus que ce soit
une enquête publique ou une commission
formelle ou un panel de juge ou
n'importe quoi ce rapporteur spécial
n'est pas encore choisi ni juste un
Trudeau dit déjà attendre ses premières
recommandations on est en train de
travailler maintenant pour nommer la
bonne personne d'ici là le Premier
ministre demande au Comité sur la
sécurité et leur enseignement qui
regroupent des élus et des sénateurs qui
ont tous une cote de sécurité de niveau
très élevé de revoir le rapport sur les
incidents de l'élection de 2021 il a
aussi mandaté l'office de surveillance
en sécurité nationale pour faire rapport
sur la façon dont les agences de
sécurité travaillent entre elles les
Canadiens sont inquiets et avec raison
de toute cette ingérence chinoise et
autres qui se passent dans notre
démocratie et ils veulent être rassurés
rapidement puis pour ne plus se
retrouver dans ce genre de situation
juste être Rudo à son ministre de la
Sécurité publique la mission de créer un
registre des agents étrangers soit des
personnes qui agissent dans l'intérêt de
leur pays en sols canadien on va
commencer le processus de consultation
cette semaine les parties d'opposition
par d'écran de fumée et de diversion
comment est-ce qu'un reportage spécial
peut-il être indépendant si les nommé
par le Premier ministre c'est pas à
proposant des enquêtes à huis clos c'est
pas en proposant de soumettre le cas de
l'ingérence étrangère du régime
communiste de Pékin a des comités
secrets qu'on va réussir à empêcher ces
actes-là pour l'ancienne ambassadeur du
Canada en Chine Guy Saint-Jacques la
solution de Justin Trudeau ne permet pas
de dissiper le brouillard
parce que il y a beaucoup de comités il
y a des groupes de haut fonctionnaires
mais la question qui se pose c'est
ultimement qui est en charge alors que
le gouvernement tente de donner des
réponses aux électeurs sans pour autant
déclencher une enquête publique
indépendante il cherche aussi des
réponses voire découpables la GRC a
ouvert une enquête pour découvrir qui
est à l'origine des fuites dans les
médias qui alimentent les soupçons des
gérances qui auraient favorisé les
libéraux ici Valérie Gamache
Radio-Canada
Ottawa